زف ثلاث قذائف قاعدين بدهم يعبوا ميه
يشربوا ضربوهم ثلاث صواريخ من الطياره
بدهم يشربوا ميه دول بشربوا ميه هذه جريمه
جديده لقوات الاحتلال وصلت مستشفى
المعمداني خلال تعبئه عائله الدايه للمياه
للمواطنين في منطقه الثلاثيني ومنطقه
المغربه قامت قوات الاحتلال بقصف عدد من
السكان وما يقارب حتى هذه اللحظه وصل الى
مستشفى الم المداني عدد كبير من الشهداء م
يا حلوه يب علينا وعلى نهارنا الاول خيفه
المرتين خبطت علينا لا تفتنا
تتف استشهد محمد الدايه يا
اخو ويوسف الدايه ويونس
الدايه وابراهيم الدايه يا اخ هذه المجزره
التي نتحدث عنها بشكل واضح جدا قوات
الاحتلال ترتكبها مع المواطنين استشهد انا
مين بده يجيب لي حقي مينش انا طبيبه ابويا
صرف علي ناله كله عشان يدرسني طب ابويا
توفى انا مش عارف اعمل له حاجه ابويا
استشهد شو كان بيعمل ابويا كان يقيم الليل
كل يوم كان يعطي من ماله
للمحتاجين هو استشهد مع هو استشهد اي
ابويا
ه كان بعضي ميه ما كان بيعمل شي ثاني ما
كان لهش اي ذنب اني غير انه بعبي
ميه ايش بدنا نعمل احنا حسبنا الله ونعم
الو هذه طبعا المجازر التي نتحدث عنها
بشكل جلي ترتكبها قوات الاحتلال وين الروح
يا الله وين وين الروح ايش ص ولك وين
الروح يا الله وين
نشرب الله معي يا الله
ظلمين يا عم مشان الله عجوب ا بس اه ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله الله هذه الحاله
التي نتحدث عنها عشرات الاصابات
وصل بفعل تعبه المياه في شارع ال قرب
المغرب الطواقم الطبيه والكوادر الطبيه في
مستشفى المعمداني تعاني الكثير من العجز
والنقص في ظل محاصره قوات الاحتلال هذه
المجزره بحق المواطنين السالمين خلال
تعبئتهم للمياه في شارع المغربي اسماعيل
الغول الجزيره مستشفى المعمداني مدينه
غزه